hello guys that's right it's time our
first real YouTube video
yeah I'm assuming this is going out
first welcome to our beautiful beautiful
apartment this is our new house all of
us live here hey Bonnie we own it
we're gonna kind of just be rolling off
of you guys might have seen it on our
Instagram before we like to play a
little game called who's most likely to
you might have participated in the
stories on Instagram but we're gonna be
actually doing it together and basically
just throwing each other under the bus
sure yeah we took a couple of the
questions from our friends at drops
Tonder stupid hey because they were just
that good
you're really good you guys play along
with us if you think that we have
something wrong then tell us in the
comments who you actually think is most
likely to do and why that thing just
read us the question I feel like without
the friends part it could have gone a
different direction but it's friends
part really sold it okay everybody sorry
what are you going you know you only did
drawing it there time I'm a dick who
your nails match your outfit oh thanks
three two one
[Applause]
I'm a hit maker
ain't that sassy she gave me anything I
mean Gina dug but then when the friends
part came in I was like I could see Jeff
having a rough weekend and be like well
it's not so bad I was gonna put you
until the friends part because you like
to unplugged you like people but not
bring them back with you like the first
half holes I get that's me I'm like you
maybe you're always like I have a friend
into that I have a friend in Wisconsin a
lot of brave I feel like Gina came back
with 10 though they'd all have to be
worthy yeah yeah this one owns a
furniture shop this one owns like an
implant oh wait this would go 3-way yeah
I'm kind of torn
it's our got to look at it Awards but I
like being surprised by no Julie did I
stop throwing to Eckstein
no what would never all right three two
one me tip and chest you guys know it's
not I think it's a rocket it's a tip I
both would be like okay guys no we need
to in the gene and I would just dive in
the bottle
no but I'm totally a man instructions
person I'm like wait step one said to
prepare yes one said read all the
instructions okay hit it I'm still
except one because you have your own
tool kit and stuff here you're a heavy
one and let me Lucy yeah that's right Oh
how much I read I would pick apart the
instructions like that's not how you
have to read them to get that far come
on that's way too easy
is it oh yeah yeah
who's wrote to the camera are you giant
dad dick are you trying to hide you it
without looking so it looks weird now
three two one oh my god you're right
that's for you I did not think about you
at all well yeah when you guys said it
was too easy I was like it's none of you
when I wasn't talked about it means you
only like make some references here and
there you know like will forward it to
everyone's detective like the FBI could
recruit her yeah oh my god but it's like
it's mostly not ex-boyfriends cuz after
we broke up I don't really care anymore
on my ex-boyfriends new girlfriend oh
yeah I meant citizen that's very true
yeah feeling like the ex wafer part that
is both yeah sometimes it's like well I
kind of need to know that you're you're
miserable about me but okay yeah I know
maybe go to it it could go two ways yeah
okay I like when they go three different
ways yeah I like it I like it
okay was that like not one person's
crazy okay three two one no dude I got
[ __ ] to do yeah I like if you're there
and I mean might minimize or her
emotions she can be like okay yeah it's
sad but also I'm here for visited well
we have something in common yeah at the
time yeah morning imagine we just walk
into the home I got so sad right and hey
I'm Gina thanks for me to the person
with a nicest suit that's Armani hold my
drink just be like it's sad that wait
which one of us tells Gina and I just
stop networking at the funeral though
like which one of you guys yeah just
probably like guys cut it out cheese
yeah I'm at the core stop it yeah I'm at
the corpse I'm like so what do you do
[Music]
anyone I'm gonna go with maybe not an
obvious one stop drawing you're running
the words really big my dick right now
realize I can touch just as Ross I with
my big toe on I'm on your toe please
Ross bye-bye ready okay one two three
Gio's I can I can it's Gina or both
[Applause]
it could have been anyone it's all
because we're pretty good with our money
okay I put Edmund foes only because
you're impulsive dudes but I don't
travel I know that's true but she could
travel like in LA or something okay I've
been like that like I just feel like it
was either gonna be it was one of you
three
because Jess did at one point be like I
don't [ __ ] care and then Gina just
like I never know what she's gonna do
but I felt like both could be it I I
almost wrote Jess just because right
after your breakup jess is like oh
forget this apartment oh yeah I was
gonna be nice but it looks good as yeah
I was we might get to live better bye
Jess emotional Tiff's though loves to
travel she went to Bora Bora by herself
got it yeah true but it was money that's
what it was planned it would be wasn't
midlife crisis right it route it could
be though you never know in the next 10
years you know you don't know what's
going on you might have another kid I
want to do it okay that's I'm a
responsible parent
oh he's easy Japanese II roll when we
start writing bad ready yeah one two
three like they could have some
connection Oh Jess you know private I am
about my life I don't like I've never
you know tell you know he does not a
[ __ ] advice she's really not yeah it
was a hundred percent Jess I gave him I
gave you a addictive thank you and money
fine I mean yeah yeah I just realize
almost like it's dude I saw Jess's
underwear earlier and they were bright
pink and I thought it was a vagina and I
was trying to like cover it up oh my
girl my white vagina is not bright a
stink like that I mean I salute you a
fuchsia
you should like you should shine intro I
said when we went to the spots on
Jessa's nipples and those were the
pinkest nipples I am aside from yours no
Jess had like like imagine like a little
pink piglet they are not that damn pain
yes they are raw look at those oh [ __ ]
they pretty pink damn real pretty
that's pretty pink Dallas and go bleach
my nipples now my skin is why would I
should bleach anything the core of
yourself Michael Jackson I know what it
means
three two one no I wrote it because her
husband is training oh then she might
like get a tattoo to surprise him and
then nah I'm not mad at the logic of it
yeah I did I I do a lot of research on
mine yeah I don't think I don't see any
other only because of your Belial that
you have that you know the meaning of
but I'm like I don't know the meaning of
it so that's the only reason why I come
on too easy
our first unanimous vote uncontested -
without a doubt one look you're on your
own name no y'all even wrote it the same
stinky dick look alright they have like
seem coming out of it it's very hot nila
it's three Street you got a dick
piercing yeah I don't like going outside
okay if I can find any excuse to not go
I'm gonna do it yeah we know
oh girl we know we know we know
one two three oh yeah you got it
yeah first of all from that severed
nikki one Nikki was saying that like
sometimes Nikki just needs to get laid
but sorry president moment present
moment would not have present moment
I've already done this in the last three
months that's why but if it were to
happen if we were all single I know that
I feel like I don't even give the right
numbers the right name in present day
Nikki like Nikki's still married to see
if she would just like I think it didn't
happen it was like no just no make no
call anything and I feel like Jess might
be like hey this was a really big
mistake I gave it to be like never
happened yeah I might give them a little
like okay sorry goodbye I don't know I
don't think my conscience could deal
with any cheating I've never cheated in
my life yeah but but I know when I was
single I don't care about them hoes
[Laughter]
y'all ready I don't watch like I feel a
tear coming up just thinking about
having to watch a scary scene both oh my
god I don't mean because I go to the
like the part I'm like I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it and then right when the
bad part time yeah now we get a video
where you guys forced me and I'd watch
so I mean we are sleeping over here
tonight I just can't have no one so if
it's a blood like if it's a blood scene
for me it's a tear jerker movies like
movie that literally like just break
your heart apart I'm like no I don't
want to do it I don't want to see it the
notebook I know I can't do movies like
that or movies like for example The
Pursuit of Happyness I've avoided that
movie because I know it's gonna make me
cry
Green Mile so that does it for damn I
haven't even thing that II should ruin
speed to pursuit of happiness when
they're in the bathroom of the train
don't tell me don't tell me not to well
we're gonna do it try not to pray
there's a movie called life itself you
should watch that one it made me cry the
other day car ran out of gas makes you
cry too like we don't count in The
Crying Game
okay guys that is that's our we're doing
it we're doing more YouTube content that
this one he learned a lot about us yes I
did I certainly learned some new things
today yeah I I feel I like me I'm dip
are you doing a dick
no she's not pink that's not didn't you
show guys it's a very muted yeah right
show at Pixar didn't know show your
[ __ ]
we're not getting paid enough for that
okay we might do another way otherwise
we'll catch you guys next week we should
be uploading more than content so come
hang out share with your friends we've
been seeing a lot of people on Twitter
lately sharing our videos with other
girls grow the network more ladies
you got right cuz I'm really hungry Oh
same oh yeah yeah alright we'll see
y'all next week see you guys hey
[Music]